[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently off the record and today since
we have christian with us who is a
certified professional by steven seagal
i
tried not to talk about them as hard as
that is we're gonna try we can't shut
the [ __ ] up about students so what we
are gonna do is we're gonna let all our
inhibitions
go and we're gonna be as ignorant
as we oh we're dropping truly
and we're gonna ask him every question
that we're not afraid to ask about
hawaiian culture since you're the
certified is that hairstyle an authentic
that's a traditional traditional yeah
because you know like those um
what do you call it like those coconut
figurines like those no no no they're
not called that the warrior mask oh yeah
the warrior mask with the with the
chicken mohawk
you know what i'm talking about yeah i'm
filipino so if it doesn't have a dick
that pops out i have no idea what are
the uh three
or yeah what are the three most common
hawaiian we'll have these answers i was
like it's like you're gonna come at me
with like trivia like it's like a quiz
what are the what are the most common
hawaiian words that everyone should know
when they step on like aloha is one of
them right
what's that what's pocket yes smoke a
weed pacalolo oh i smoke weed yeah okay
what else do you say pacalola there's
mahalo that one's pretty what's that
[ __ ] you
dude people think mahalo means trash
because it's on the trash cans
wow
people are dumb but what does that mean
it means thank you thank you thank you
but in south park you have the mahalo
rewards card which makes you a local
yeah
best episode ever you're a local
what else is what's another word
everyone should know
oh man howly oh that's probably my
favorite word why is that your favorite
word explain to the viewers probably for
everyone that's not from hawaii if you
go to hawaii you're called a halley
you're being welcomed by the locals
[Laughter]
that's like saying you're [ __ ] sick
yeah especially if you have like white
skin and blonde hair right especially if
there's a [ __ ] before it yeah and
they'll be like [ __ ] [ __ ] sick
like you know when you go that's sick
it's like oh that's sick
or if you go that's [ __ ] sick it's
cool it's like you [ __ ] howling and
they love it when you're a newcomer and
you're surfing yeah and you take the
first wave
oh because then they go [ __ ] holly
and then they say [ __ ] that person's
usually like submerged in the water
you killed the first graveyard oh that's
a [ __ ] holly right there so all like
newcomers get first wave rights
yeah
we're teaching people how to get [ __ ]
up in hawaii if you're not from there
and you're white you should go there
[Laughter]
right away what's up
would i be considered halley too is
highly only for white people is highly
just for anyone not hawaiian are we
halley's how we actually like the word
it kind of just gets
crushed down to foreigner in a way but
howly like
or like the term is actually used for
people that disrespect traditional
hawaiian cultures and like it's a lot of
like people that come into hawaii with
like this chip on their shoulder like
like disrespect karen's right yeah
essentially just the way that people see
karen's at like a store like i want to
talk to the manager like people that
feel entitled going to entitled i see
the island because there's like a lot of
history like yeah back like it's still
technically illegally taken is it
because they treat the island as oh this
is my summer getaway like yeah so they
don't treat it like it's its own cause
i'm gonna piss on the coral and [ __ ]
make it mutate into a [ __ ] hallie
taking her wave and pissing the coral
not even using reef safe sunscreen too
what do you think about when haole gets
used and then people accuse that of
being like right that's as bad as the n
word
ah because i've heard that [ __ ] okay
i love that so like you guys ever see
that john mullaney special where he's
talking about the n-word
so if we're comparing
a word with the n-word if we're
comparing the flagrant the flagrancy of
two words
if we're not even saying what one word
is that's the worst word that's like the
bit from the joke so people comparing
any word to the n word and you're not
even saying the n word it's like it's
not the same thing
yes
is it even considered like a racial
thing
i mean it's not really a racial thing
but it kind of defaults to white person
yeah yeah because it's default windows
settings yeah
like when you're bringing that up you
don't know which one's worse the h word
or the n word you're saying hallie or n
word because you're just censoring
yourself on the other one already
there's probably a lot of people
watching like
shows how only bad
which one is it someone runs out of
restaurant goes there's a hallie in
there when you go in are you gonna
really scan the room are you gonna know
who they're talking about
wait someone running outside a
restaurant going holy
[Laughter]
the werewolf
[Laughter]
and a white guy with dreadlocks come out
with a surfboard like dude what's the
problem
i was born here
oh yeah so do locals really
how do locals actually feel about
tourists
there's um there are people that there's
a spectrum there's definitely a lot of
people that just don't want anyone
coming to hawaii at all because the
especially with kovid like the hawaiian
bloodline
isn't used to the sars strain of virus
because they're on an island you know so
they haven't like evolved to become like
what's it called like immune to that
whereas there's a lot of people like
from europe and the united states that
have like been like chinese
[Laughter]
that have been like exposed to that like
family of virus
what do you mean joe what are you
talking about
i'm just trying to be diverse here cause
like you know you missed you you missed
out on the asians bro
and i want to represent
chad
you're not even chinese
when you were growing up then did you
used to like did you used to [ __ ] with
tourists at all like no i do because i
kind of have a weird complex there too
where my dad is in the military
so it's like i'm like yeah guys i were
you born there no i was born in san
diego yeah so you're not considering no
like so you can't be considered hawaiian
though no like you can only be hawaiian
if you have hawaiian blood i don't know
i mean like that's the true hawaiian
that's okay because there's a there's a
you're hawaiian like native hawaiian
right and then there's like the local
like because like your
great-grandparents worked on the
plantations or like you were born there
that's like there's definitely like i
was
raised there so it's like a that's
already like a different thing for being
like hawaiian blood so do the hawaiian
blood people call the locals howlies
i don't think so howly hierarchy what
happens to hawaiian lugs
yeah what's the levels
because the way i thought thought about
it
there's there's hawaiian native hawaiian
put that one in here and then there's
the locals
and even within the locals there's white
locals that have been there for
generations yeah
oh yeah that are that are a part of the
community and then there's transplants
people that move there and then there's
a tourist right yeah so that's that's
how that's the highest that's the
hierarchy right and then the and then
the horizon
am i missing anything
between the tourists and the transplants
there's the billionaires with vacation
homes that go there once every five
years sucks
my favorite are the zucks
because for me as an outsider
whoever has the thickest pigeon accent
is the authority oh definitely i can't
understand this dude you tell me
everything i'll do whatever you want me
to do
you know i'd be hearing more pigeon in
[ __ ] las vegas than i do in hawaii
now
let's show you over at unlv yeah i got
so many neighbors speaking pidgin and
they just came here from hawaii and [ __ ]
and i'm like oh [ __ ] this is the nice
island people like put on a thicker
pigeon accent to
seem good
yeah a hundred percent i got a friend
who grew up in california and he moved
to hawaii like in college yeah and then
he's full on pigeon speaking now i mean
it definitely happened
it kicks in later in life yeah like i've
seen it happen like that where like i've
had a friend that like moved there for
college and then she was there for like
six years and now she has a pigeon
accent like i don't know i guess it
happens six years yeah that's a long
time though yeah i mean i feel like
she's adopted by then you know but i
there are people that go there first
year of college that try to like pick up
on it and it's so forced
shoots bra yeah i'm like oh the aina the
aina you gotta respect the aina bra oh
[Laughter]
european tours within like 10 minutes
i'm copying them
i don't even know that i am i'm just
trying to like you know what i mean so i
get it try to be understood it's a
survival mechanism yeah you kind of pick
up on other people's slang you know holy
brother
[Laughter]
imagine steve dude
sorry you start responding with this
[ __ ] yeah i've had times where i met
like two people both from hawaii that
are now living here and then one of them
is like speaking real pigeon and then
the other guy goes
hey back in hawaii that dude never
sounds like that yeah oh really so they
so they speak like us and then when they
come to the mainland they're like i
gotta represent bro yeah to be more
unique here it's like they'll like be
more oh i'm hawaiian i haven't the
opposite when i go back home and i'm
with my friends i feel it instantly
coming down yeah like i changed my life
yeah it's right here too yeah like it
comes out of me i'm like wow i forgot to
talk like that yeah i mean today's video
is brought to you by audible all right
so you know i'm now a vegas resident and
we come down to la to film jk news and
it's about a good four hour drive you
know and during that time
i look at the desert
i listen to music
i play with my fingers and there's a lot
of things that happen but i want to be
productive so what i ended up doing was
listening to audio books and right now
i'm listening to tony robbins the power
the awaken the power within i might be
butchering the title but if it's it's
something along those lines right yeah
and i was able to knock out a lot of
that book and it was really
something that was like good because i
need something to wake me up i need some
good energy i don't want a boring book i
want something that's like inspirational
and a lot of the times like listening to
those kind of things it's very like all
right i'm fired up i'm motivated let's
go and by the time i get to la i'm in
work mode what's dope about audible is
they're your one-stop shop for your
listening entertainment so they have
audio books but they also got podcasts
they got theatrical stuff they got
originals they even have guided wellness
so anything that you're looking for
whether it is for a long-term
entertainment where you're driving for
four hours or if it's just something
super short uh you can find all of that
stuff on audible so if you want to try
out audible new members can try audible
out for free for 30 days just go to
audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500 to try it out but then when i'm
out here even when i'm in new york like
it changes when you're in new york do
you change the eggs
i'm [ __ ] walking don't you [ __ ] hey
you [ __ ] hell is the [ __ ] out of here
what are you doing
hey it's my taxi cab what are you doing
you call this [ __ ]
mother makes pokey pokey than this
who puts this [ __ ] [ __ ] in
he's like i'm surfing here
stupid
can't get [ __ ] in the mainland he's
culturally confused
what's um
is the sea turtle the national
mascot of hawaii
i think it's the monk seal the hawaiian
monks
yo they're so chill man they hang out on
the beach yeah oh y'all also if you're a
tourist and you want to make money go
ahead go ahead and touch one of those
[Laughter]
the more monk seals you can pat the more
money you make and they make it they
make it again it's a snap card and if
you get all of them you get a nft
you get a board ape
you get a pork monk
that's also like annoying because like
tour i guess they just don't know that
you're not allowed to go up to him
they'll like walk up to him and like
you're not even supposed to be within
like a certain range like wow if there's
a lifeguard on the beach they'll like
tape it off because like the monkey will
like just like nap on the beach
but like the tourists will just go up to
it like want to take pictures oh yeah
it's just so annoying
i've seen tourists trying to pick up
turtles yeah that's like dudes you can
go you can go to jail for that yeah and
but they'll give you a bunch of money
though if you do that yeah you'll get oh
yeah it's fine yeah
fail yourself out i went on this
snorkeling trip where it's one of those
where like you're on a boat right and
they take you in the middle of the ocean
so there's way more wildlife because
it's not on the beach
and then they said don't touch the
turtles so like i'm swimming and then a
turtle is swimming towards me and you
could just see like years of like moss
and like algae on the turtle's back like
oh i see why they don't want to touch it
because they'll you'll rub it off and
it's protective right so as it's
swimming i'm like trying to get out of
the way yeah then you see all these
[ __ ] howlies reaching for
all these
[ __ ] howlies dude [ __ ] alley will
get the [ __ ] away from that [ __ ]
turtle you [ __ ] out
i just i just wish we had like we can
call people howie's out here i know
because it's a fun word it is but it is
very unique to hawaii so you guys
adopted the word hapa we adopted it
really yeah like hapa like the true hapa
is like hawaiian blood with like mixed
with other people now it's just like
half white half asian now yeah is half a
japanese or i originally thought it was
japanese and white no hapa is like
that's cool i thought it was japanese
because hapa just means half yeah but
it's it's not the right term to use
either
but you might be right because i grew up
in a japanese and kind of hawaiian
japanese neighborhood it's like hawaiian
and japanese yeah so they
when they spoke a lot of the pigeon i
thought that's just how old japanese
people spoke like because i thought they
had broken english but they were
actually speaking pidgin
so then
i'm not too sure
i grew up thinking that but it's
actually not a word that my grandma used
either so because the the correct term
is called a freak
with
i think they call them hafu in japanese
it's just it's just english
like half white half japanese in japan
yeah but but but the but what my grandma
used to call them uh them is basically
ainoko
oh that's like a filipino thing ain't no
coke
what does arnoco mean
in filipino it's like it's like when you
say it's like going oh no oh my god yeah
it's like oh really oh no it's afraid
the direct translation is kid made from
love
wow because the concept is you must
really love each other to violate isn't
every kid made from love no but like
when you're you're violating
america that's [ __ ] but they don't
marry for love that's why oh yeah
i see well pidgin is a combination of
like hawaiian chinese portuguese english
japanese and tagalog or like and like
because you guys say show you too right
for soy sauce and that's japanese right
mm-hmm show you
the brand yeah yeah like sweet pops away
or something no it's japanese that's
just that's a japanese way of saying soy
sauce oh so that's all that it is it's
just soy sauce is simon just a hawaii
thing yeah we don't have simon yeah i
don't know what that is that might be
chinese there's stuff in the cabbage
salmon's just like wrong it's the four
it's the circle with the four colors
oh yeah
oh my god
foiled again
yeah because the [ __ ] that i grew up on
i thought it was japanese and then i
realized oh that's just pigeon that's
hawaiian [ __ ] that's dude it's like its
own legal language now it's a legal
language damn who called it pidgin in
the first place huh who called it pidgey
i don't know and it's not even spelled
like the bird no it's p-i-d-g-i-n
i don't know why it's called that but
it's not a thing that's ever taught
right it's just no you kind of just
dude
that would be wild
it's for happy literally
you literally come out of the womb and
you just go hey brother
hey right now so the word of the day is
choke this means a lot
what's broke the mouth broke the mouth
when the food's so good oh the food
broke the mouth hey what's the wrong
answer what's this oh broke the mouth uh
that's when you're white in hawaii i
broke them out
oh what's when it's nasty
broke the ass
like if it tastes disgusting oh yeah is
there a word a pigeon term for that
or is this everything in hawaii's
delicious so you don't have i don't
think if there's ever bad food in hawaii
guys what if l opened up like a
dude the lnls here are like not the same
no yeah it's because they have to source
local ingredients yeah i was like whoa
this is like how is it different from
here than in uh i don't know the food
just tastes different i don't know how
to explain it it's not as good because
they need samoan guys cooking it that's
what i've been saying you can't have
puerto rican guys cooking l
you can't get puerto rican guys
puerto ricans and mexicans
come on man there is a spot here though
in huntington beach called the hawaiian
kitchen that's like the best hawaiian
food i've ever had outside of hawaii oh
wow better than the king's hawaiian
restaurant in torrance oh i've never
been there
where's that you gotta go to las vegas
man they got like [ __ ]
hella good ass places i went to one
recently uncle frank's he's a fan of our
channel i didn't know he was trying to
get us to go there i just shot out i
just walked in one day and he goes joe
you're not paying today and i'm like
what
why i'm gonna break the mouth
cause you're a holly cause you're a
halloween you'll be paying for that
later
i hate you i'ma [ __ ] you up
it was good no like if you're ever in
vegas
i swear to god there's probably better
like hawaiian local joints in vegas than
i did here in l.a or the differences in
l.a you got to [ __ ] drive like you
got to go to huntington beach you got to
go to torrance or gardena you got to go
to all these different places for that
one restaurant right we're in vegas it's
everything's like 20 minutes away
there's hella good pokey there's like
[ __ ] five really solid hawaiian
restaurants there's a lot of good spots
yeah they have a zippy's in vegas too
right oh they do they do yeah i think
that's crazy what's your go-to meal at
zucchini green fried chicken
all right no mac
that's last bro i had friends that get
no rice all mack is the most disgusting
[ __ ] a tub of like mayonnaise and
korean fried chicken
damn hardcore that's bubblegum what what
exactly is a luau a
what's a luau
like what like what exactly is it yeah
people go let's [ __ ] we should have a
luau what does that mean man a lot of
the luau stuff is all like
for tourists like that's like not even
like traditional like yeah a lot of the
stuff they do is like
you don't [ __ ] fire dance with your
homies after a fat ass meal
after every meal
that's [ __ ] up man that'll be fire
dancing exactly what's traditional
hawaiian but there's a lot of the like a
lot of the stuff that's done at the luau
now is just all like hollywood
westernized stuff like if you're going
to like the like four seasons you're
going to the daily luau or whatever yeah
like dude they got that [ __ ] down to a
science you know what i mean it's like a
vegas show yeah it's like a medieval
times but the hawaiian version what
about when they're cooking what about
when they're cooking the pig under the
ground and [ __ ] is that like pretty
legit [ __ ] there's something about i
forgot what it was but there's something
about that that's like also wrong like
that really
yeah i forgot what it was all that i
learned about was a lie and hawaii i
think also the when they cook the pig
underground at the luau they're not
actually doing that apparently it's not
really because dude you can't do it like
all the time or like
to feed that many people yeah you know
so there's a lot of it that they need a
commercial kitchen is staged yeah so
they like they do one
they do they'll just show like oh look
that's the sand pit where they're
cooking the pig right now but then when
it's like
10 000 people yeah that's not yeah
that's clever clever yeah that's the
performance though what do like uh real
hawaiians think about the whole don't
visit hawaii um like mainlanders
well the thing was the coveted reasoning
i think is pretty valid where the native
hawaiians are more prone to like
drastic like uh repercussions from kovid
like they won't just get sick like
they'll get sick sick and get long
covered because they're not used to that
sars thing so people were pissed when
people are going like oh flies are cheap
i'm gonna pull up you know and cough on
the beach and stuff
so people were
people are actually mad but also it's
like the cost of living is crazy right
now oh yeah yo i heard a lot of people
[ __ ] moved in oh dude people are like
pulling up i was i was looking at this
duplex pre-covet it was 700 thousand
right i went back to check it out right
now that's just like 1.5 million now oh
doubled
even my parents house
the
their like the property value went up by
like
almost two times since they moved in
just like just like the like they
refinanced that house like so many times
like and they're gonna make money on it
when they sell it and move again because
it's just like the property value of
hawaii is going up so people are like
the native hawaiians that have been
there for years can't even afford to
live there anymore yeah so that's why
they're pissed they're just like because
how does your next generation afford
yeah like get a house you know yeah
and a lot of people like live off the
land and stuff and now they can't afford
to do that because because there's an
influencer that wants to live off the
land they're gonna [ __ ] buy a grass
hut for a million dollars so they can
make youtube videos of how they're
[ __ ] living this organic life and
[ __ ] and then and then there's this
hawaiian family that has to move to
oregon and [ __ ] and just they're like
moving to vegas because
i know
yo all of my neighbor i feel like i got
more of hawaii and vegas than in hawaii
there's a [ __ ] ton of hawaiians in vegas
and uh
bella view i think washington wow oh
yeah there's like a lot of bellevue yeah
how did that start i don't know i think
they're giving some sort of incentive i
have a lot of friends that move there
but yeah i have a couple of like
hawaiian friends in the fitness like
industry and they all live there wow but
i mean it makes sense too because like
let's say you're making a
like 50k a year income right and then
like there's this family home that you
guys bought for like 300 grand and all
of a sudden that shit's like 2 million
and then i mean your job is still like
40 50k or even if you're making 100k on
the island that's still not that much
money right so your house is now two mil
or one mil even and you're just like you
know what
i can sell this go to vegas have a sick
ass place for like less than half a mil
and i can retire
and i think because a lot of my friends
out there like they're working multiple
jobs and [ __ ] they're like you know and
they got regular jobs like [ __ ]
teachers and contractors and all that
stuff
and it's crazy dude i'm just like it
sucks because everything else is like
beverly hills prices yeah
man also just general cost of living
like groceries are really expensive
everything's like imported so it's just
naturally more expensive
yeah like all the stuff you see on like
the like fast food too like all the
deals you see it's like just expected to
be like the wendy's four for four you
know why it's a five for four
oh [ __ ] i mean yeah like stuff like
that's always gonna be more expensive
you know like the dollar menu is
actually a dollar 25
you know
damn how much is arizona iced tea
that one actually stays a dollar i don't
know how they pull it off those guys are
like arizona babies yeah those guys are
some dependable
[Laughter]
howie we can get behind
you